[Musique]
terminus jeunesse en tout le monde
aum
si john mack monomanie faisons l'amour
sans faire attention aux mystères et
quatre fois par quoi
[Musique]
tu vois ça ça c'est un vrai palace un
trousseau comme lui je décroche
non bah c'est quand même non pour ton
courage à deux mains
[Musique]
voilà ça c'est manas à c'était plus fort
que ce que j'ai fait
[Musique]
soutire manquerait sans faire dans la
poubelle
si tu viens sur mon père juif autre
chose non à part et déguisés
jean-patrice et c'est bon une pelouse
interdite sans vergogne la piété claque
une photo sur facebook lite 3 soleil je
me retourne aux deux camps quelqu'un dit
gagik les couilles des majuscules ans
débuteront comme on jette un tac au tac
rally découvert dans la piscine secours
au bord du bassin
jamais en fait
bas tarifs assainissement
confidentialité est fier de vous
vous avez conscience que vous déshonorez
totalement l'esprit badass ah bon battre
nadal s'est pas seulement prendre une
voie énervé c'est une attitude faire des
trucs phénoménal
tu es nominaux c'est comme ses confrères
ne me décevez plus
[Musique]
quand je vais au tableau les conditions
sur mon pare-brise leur aidé à cacher
menne batteur jim hall de surface utile
je l'aï promis dimanche que les ports
caucase deux fois la suite 8,4 soit mais
pas d amour poteau c'est qu'ils peuvent
à d'ascq
si toi aussi tu es balaci cliquer ici
enfin sauf si tout cas personne peut
donner dans 20 ans à personne
par contre si tu es un badass sur mobile
reste sur la playlist
enfin sans vouloir te te commandés